you can see right there on your screen
Bank just dick killed away from 1000 you
look like it's not going to happen today
big buy one get one on the board you've
gotta wait you got to get it from kt
rolster I think everybody should help me
out get that thousand kills to unhealthy
Allen comes down box not going to
connect on the bang he's still funny
coming back wolf however gets matched up
dragged in scores all the way so just be
another kill coming through mana
the fear was we pick you up at the front
line but the cost of his life they are
air people to answer once on two opens
you go hunter is what that is
contributor around on to score the
lateral damage from Pina eggs out the
spider and that was the thousand
skillful bang as well the crowd just
realizes the big cheer comes through so
thousand kills on Samana feels good
a little bit rough bang in trouble here
he's getting flamed uses that ultimate
tries to stay invisible
oh he dodges the cue he got people to
let it calm play my back he's dead man
no I guess away in the lantern call it
in trouble now the ignite stings related
Johnny's oh he's gonna give his life for
the baron bank assets are you coming it
oh they got the Baron then SKT a triple
jump the resets all day making a Quadra
giving it is big acid [ __ ] Masek camera
bag definitely gonna be a win Francky
room is grunting anything okay on came
on pro came on and a condom to-
including a tank car whoa manages to alt
can he get away with the disengage allow
for bar coming from behind and now
knowledge in in a bit of trouble fake
reveals of damage and look at it all
coming in for a bank now Bank is going
to clean up this fight easily PAOK I
grab the kill Aloka defensive man Lauren
Lauren troll stolen from him he gets the
Quadra though Quadra kill for bang on
distress donna with that twisted advance
and they're actually going to turn this
around Baker using the emperor's divide
there the Rockets coming in but the
cleanup from bang III Autoweek just
behind the wall and then gets on the
bang but there's the qss once again and
a double kill from bang who is just so
predict triple kill one
Creek Hill and are they going to get the
Penta bar and wants to hand it over
gorilla gonna get fish gorilla gonna get
the Penta or bang that is SK Telecom
first specta of the season for Sequoia
with an kazoos expansions and then Tom
botando tickets had a cough cough
walking down choreo and saxophones with
no cages having the wrong time or
someone they're working at something or
managed to get out of it with a flash
valve Lauren just brawling with everyone
wolf looking for opportunities as well
to make getting the bad guys there's a
knock come on the face oh they take down
safe side let's go back up here just
bang guess in the back
oh man Lucien you don't want him in your
bag line shy getting low nice natural
charge from cocoa but ambition still
taking off my faker bang continuing to
chase gets the double low health he's
going to back away and heal up a little
bit on the rug where is the rest of VJ
though DJ needs to protect their top
laner they can't he goes down get
another kill for bang bang he tries to
come inflate away by madlife calling
it's nobody but the rabid things all
comes in it's a double kill for bang
already SK Telecom ready to close this
one out
bang OH first game here o Gianna where
the elf DK and we are the chock full of
surprises I like it but going up against
bang the potential best in the world
about go ahead that Katie versus jet air
we go in we not jumping in great health
does come through so flower Ally for the
time being with meetings you know to be
able to finish the ball bag running for
his life
Jukes out on the deadly floors we know
him through a node a bag he doesn't go
down and they pick up the kill a double
kill for peanut put a second one on the
board
Oh bang to be recalling on top of a war
on you stands on the line hanging by all
- OH
that bang is so good gets the kill that
Mickey would spot as we just goes back
to mid oh there's Tina corruption come
on in and huge amount of damage down
goes that Bindra sake now is exhausted
one more hit will do it and that is
going to be in a double kill for virus
in the bot lane double kill for SKT at
this point is so bad for the rosh tiger
even the exhaust coming down but Otero
is in a bunch of trouble the creek
coming on out they're going to try to
have the skill on over to bang be right
there on your screen bang just six kills
away from 1,000 in LC camp we only have
two players who are lck 1000 killers was
going to call them was Baker across
first and then it was prayed a lot on
the line for both of these teams go
ahead get on over it for Game one it's
SK Telecom vs. samsung galaxy he's going
to go down he's still going forward
trying to get rid of that maokai a
sheriff connects on a wolf so healthy in
the fearsome arrow comes up with a kill
for bang now just four away from 1,000
guilt working the same time Haru gotta
quit easily ropes away resume straight
comes down dragons rage straight into
the piercing arrow bang comes up with
yet another kill three more to go
for 1000 we'll see what the end because
could have been bang also and yes it
will be bang who kills Shawn of that
1000 kills in lck Tuscan fire but I need
to protect your clothing your looks like
it's not going to happen today bank buy
one get one on the board just meets it
if only you would give it over to them
looks likes it says not today buddy
you've got to wait you got to get it
from kt rolster 1,000 kills not going to
happen today but MKT still pick up a 2-0
sometimes players say they don't know
about statistics they knew about it here
back matter if I get 2,000 kills a night
you know it's all about you winning the
game you would recognized in Ione Isis
another guy comes down box not gonna
connect on the bank he's still fighting
fight back wolf however gets matched up
dragged in scores on the way but just be
another kill coming through mata just
fearless like making up in front line
but a costume is life they are air able
to answer one on two opened he goes but
that is Juvia turnaround on to score
collateral damage from Tina takes out
the spider and that was the thousand
skills of bang as well the crowd just
realizes a big cheer comes through so
thousand kills on tamada feels good you
know I always told my teammates don't
worry about my thousand kill or whatever
or you know I'm just worried about
winning the game and I'm glad we got
that thanks for watching if you want
more great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button